before position my clothes expected to
be a contribute there's a steal by Paul
George took it right away from Jackson
throw it down the mid-late Stussy little
pep in his death Paul George's took the
router on
you know it's kind of like you when you
hold that piece of cake and I want it
I'm just gonna arrest you player John
Jackson blocked the shot now the
turnover
kanan snags it Mariza he got blocked on
the other end by Paul George we on the
shot clock
we're just staying in what comes up the
steal and give them right back in
Westbrook dancing in crank that thing up
the fourth here the speed the game is
changing the turnovers under again just
like the first half
[Applause]
Westbrook one man to beat
turns up this tree at home for going to
to the N for game homestand after
starting the season to the 2nd of really
tough road games there's a steal
something that Oklahoma City does very
well while he wears number 12 on his
white jersey Steven a dangerous pass
picked off by Westbrook hopefully that
won't get him gone
[Applause]
[Music]
and the ripple way
George steals away Cody Zeller
results in a border
Russell's gonna exploit whatever you
give him well that's what a lot of the
wizards opponents whose Westbrook comes
up with a steal their clothes it down
Westbrook as we noted in the open is
driving the bus jumps the passing lane
end to end so so fast in this second the
shuttle falling from downtown Suns
that's a great bust up here by the
Thunder if they're watching it he's
landed in nothing slithery about that
just lightly quick hands for Jackson but
then it's smothered on the other not
enough to Jim yeah not a good decision
there you stole the ball to those the
best defenders in the league right there
in front of you cauley-stein blocked and
it jumped balls only Stein with the
rejection from the Thunder this right
here Paul George doesn't give up on the
play
good catch is Willie on a layup good
plate warriors 1 for 7 from the field
over 4 from 3 but a steal by Westbrook
he was booed on the opening tip he'll
lay it in on the other end
[Music]
well that's another steal as I said
they've got 11 a game with four to have
to go in the second quarter more
defenses Westbrook sniffed out that lob
pass good job funny Kevin Durant as well
you did a good job baby that turnover
Russell Westbrook to you why scrub cans
the three and you take it you run and
jeremy'll and there's a turnover good
pressure on the ball ball George
Thwaites hesitates to the road guards up
above the rim mica the defense into
offense Paul George he'd play to guys
you got to play make us Nicholas platoon
on the perimeter hitting the threes and
beers back on birdie putt and a turnover
let's cook out of the perimeter dishes
it off burden cuts across and close
Paul George lines it up and the rebound
the merge the George intercept the pass
knifing his way aboard jump kitchen
scores you grab that the whole way and
if he knows he's got to do your kit move
there by Stephen at he puts into paint a
nice cool baseline left it away here
come the Thunder off the steel the law
he got a derby on this play and this is
what I got sweet
[Applause]
Thunder getting out of the run that
frontcourt of Atlanta man with that
that's what you want to see you don't
put it here high tunnel valve front Josh
it does stop it's just great
anticipation man this is why he's neat
the mph Steelers
you know if I'm playing against Paul
George I'm afraid to pass the ball for
Luke to the paint
- back outside picked off by Paul George
George with the drive and a scoop and a
store in sin kicks it out Levine on the
move
knocked away and stolen
is Paul's lost he lost Lowrey to try to
limit those empty possessions
steal more turnovers
- Roxanna
- with 933 left the third out between
the circles
that's hot
George - sure
quick quick basket what is watch the
speed right here there's this deal with
all defensive player Paul dork we'll
watch out fast true dur accelerates and
blows right by Justin holiday for that
layup just beautiful touch of these
shows Georgia game got that fall on the
passing lane those mad at the Red Hat
the angle and spins it home nice steal
group by Paul George reading that pass
no this is his second billing of the
first quarter like that I don't use
threw the ball out front like that he
creates your old office just as we well
sometimes you can get yourself started
offensively by making a play like that
down takes on Westbrook couldn't get a
sex
[Applause]
unbelievable content
Falls no coal
Ferguson go to three change of events
there on the switch it's Westbrook
defending part harden gets past them and
Westbrook swats it off the window like
James Harden gets past
Russell Westbrook says no sir points so
far trying to shake Paul George and
Paul's
taken away by shrewder and he gives
George a little Christmas gift after the
D on the other end man Wartortle is game
anybody in the league 17 there's a turn
older Oh
George what anticipation will read to
steal that outlet mouse westgroup you
know he's in no man's land hog horse
gets that shot so often on so many teams
great great by Westbrook sets up the
two-on-one Ferguson somehow just need
the shot deflection by Newark [ __ ] now
he's running the break but Paul George
with the steal
Westbrook gives it up
grant finishes off glass no way being
under 500 he was going to be in the next
button he's right back in the
conversation Westbrook picks the pocket
up Lillard the NBA leader in steals
Westbrook gets the layup on the other
end to make consistent shots man he is
relentless what he does expenditure of
energy lead of the game for OKC Wiggins
so rare major surprise when he misses
[Applause]
Andrew Wiggins he's been solid all night
good block by rough going on Thursday
night was dead to the rim
the damage is right here about the poked
away victims Russell Westbrook the
Lakers want him playing downhill talking
to coach booth walk before the game he
says listen this is a quiet guys he
turns it over let's look on the two of
them
air Oklahoma City you're very happy
you're one in five in your last six you
start this game all hop on a snail how
about that one came from nowhere and the
room service at the other end group here
and now you're gonna see when if you
turn your back right there you turn you
back and look the other way he's coming
from the blind saw not real gamble a so
as well as George
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
talk about access denied at the rim ball
George just perfect timing it's been a
tightly contested game call him had it
knocked away in a steal by George George
get around you steal the ball this far
out front
you literally create your own office the
bunker that is one D okay how about that
he's the point where delay the
basketball coverage transition again
Jackson and another finish it